KAS I'm G bring you up in a in a little
bit no no no not you not you not you
Muhammad I was talking to my brother
D okay yeah you could you can chill how
you doing
Zozo I'm fine thanks you I'm good man
I'm blessed and highly favored by the
Lord Jesus Christ I can feel your anger
from here you can feel my
anger yeah oh anger there's no anger
here I think um no I'm just uh I'm just
U um you're just playing not funny
no no the thing is why come up
here not about that why I'm coming here
is the reason is I'm I'm asking how to
guide a blind man well well this is what
you do you want to take him by the hand
and you want to lead them to Christ make
sure you're on the road of Christ
ignorance ignorance is the problem for
me if you're born are you saying you're
too ignorant to to lead a blind man
Muslim not not me
uh I was born as a Muslim I was raised
as a Muslim but the thing is I always
ask question all the people who was
Muslim in heaven the rest is in hell so
my brother is uh uh he went
extreme okay on that Pat oh you're
saying you're talking about the guy that
was just up here no no no about my
brother he saying he's saying his
brother bought bought a beeper that's
what he's trying to say oh got it yeah
okay okay all
right so so so um why I'm asking is is a
um I've always wondered why is only in
Islam we we we the people go to heaven
and rest is in
hell that that's not what I'm asking I'm
asking about Muhammad and the Bible
brother no I cannot prove that because
I'm I'm coning to live the religion yeah
s like he's about to leave Islam that's
what it sounds
like yeah definitely definitely because
uh I have thought about it a very long
time so when when your brother uh went
the road that he went did that have that
shake you up that like showed you that
that can't be from
God no when he starting to uh go extreme
he's starting to avoid to listen to
music in his house no picture on the
walls uh AV voiding to have Christian
friends avoiding a lot of things and you
know and I I got I got scared of it I
like this is this is not how you follow
a
religion but but that that'd be scary if
that was like actually what Islam taught
though
right that's what they thought because
uh that's how you grew up and uh it's a
mentality and it's a lifestyle it's like
U it's hard to um
uh I don't know how to express myself
but we understand you for for for you
toh say that Pro Muhammad was in the
Bible
it's it's like finding a a fairy tale
absolutely you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right so I'm I am
abolished about people how they behave
you know many people they they think
they know about the the religion
especially in Islam 90% 95% they don't
read they only listen to the Imam what
they say but they don't read themselves
they they don't have this knowledge to
ask question in Islam if you ask
question it's Haram it's forbidden
that's
true so that's why I ask you how can you
take a blind man because I my brother is
really blind my friend
it's you know uh he changed his um his
daughter's name to Aisha and that freaks
me that
that's that makes me angry a lot angry I
see
yeah well I I think the first the first
step my brother is
one like for you personally you would
you yourself would have to you know come
into the truth so that you can give your
brother the truth you know what I mean
yeah
but but how it's not that easy just
understand well uh ignorance is the
problem and and that's what we're here
for though that's what we're here
for I follow you a very long time and I
appreciate what you do you know and I
appreciate that you educate people it's
and many people don't have this
mentality to educate themselves and they
don't ask question they don't ask the
right question they always seek to the
or what the neighbors said to them what
the friends tell them you know they
don't seek for themselves and and and on
myself I almost trying to seek okay
where to ask the right question who is
the right who is wrong what can I do
children how can I teach them because my
children asked me who's God who's God
and one day my son come home and said
yeah you know I just today they taught
me in school Jesus Is God I said
wow H they taught in school it's hard
for me to express it this to my brother
because he have told
you
know um yeah I I think I think a good
way a a good way that's going to be able
to reach your brother is you're going to
have you know um one is you coming into
the truth of Christ and you know getting
a solid foundation in Christ and then
also being able to go into the Quran and
show your brother these things that what
the Quran actually says what it actually
teaches um and
show him the falsehood in in it you that
it'll it'll have to do with your
education yourself and it's not going to
be at a snap of a finger it's going to
take some time it's okay like one of our
brothers David wood he was friends best
friends with a Muslim for years and
years and years and years until he
finally you know came you know woke up
so it'll take some time you know and God
will do what he does but for you you
educate yourself on Christ the truth of
Christ
get your foundation solid in that then
also learn for yourself start reading
the Quran and what it says about the
previous scriptures how they're true
what it really says about Allah what the
hadiths really teach about Muhammad and
his character yeah right and then you
show your brother the
stuff yeah I have done that I trying to
show him all the Hadith but he says no
I'm Sunni we don't believe in this we
don't believe in that we don't believe
in this said but don't believe in don't
believe in what
in the because they say it's because he
we are Sunni and we're not Shia and and
he says that many of this Hadith is not
correct because this is what Shia have
wrote down the
Hadith yes are you not so you're not
showing him Sunni
sources I have done that but he's still
ignorant I said to him but this is not
correct way to he must be in like a
mosque or like under some sort of
leadership like someone is like
brainwashing him right he he's going to
be under someone's teaching yeah but a
lot trust me and he consider he
considered them the people in the mosque
more like a brother than he as a brother
and this is a danger path he taking and
Zoo to be honest with you to be honest
with you like God logic said the first
thing that you need to do is actually I
know you say you're like one foot out of
Islam but you need to get out of it all
together and come to Jesus because then
you can have Assurance for your eternal
life there's no myths there's no Fairy
Tail you know for a fact that you have a
relationship with the Living God that he
loves you he cares for you but the thing
is why I wake up is because I have I
have encountered a white man three times
in my dreams he always telling me to
read and follow this path but I can't
see the path read what did he tell you
to read uh he haven't said anything to
me yet and that's the thing is he said
to me you have to wake up you you have
to take this path because the way this
path I'm on is not a good path he always
warning me for this path well you know
what Jesus said right he said I am the
way truth sorry to interrupt I'm not
saying that he's white but his clothes
is white I can't see his face I can't
see we know what you're
saying yeah you're saying
yeah when when Jesus when Jesus was on
the Mount of transfiguration it says
that his his robes were so white whiter
than
any uh like whiter than you can ever
imagine because it's the glory of God
you're not saying skin color you're just
saying that that's his glory you saw so
so Jesus said he is the way he's that
path and just like just like what what
God just referenced now or Brother David
wood this this brother that he spoke
with for years and years and years he
had a dream as well
and this dream Jesus appeared to him in
his dream as well and he and he there
was a door and nabia was outside the
door and Jesus was telling to come
in and that's what Jesus is telling you
to do he said he's knocking at your door
telling you to
come well
it's you know I'm very confused you know
and I called my mom just to take a you
know just just ask her a question
because I have a daughter and I said hey
Mom uh there's a guy he's 53 years old
and he want to marry my daughter she's
80 years old my mom said who's this guy
I'm going to kill you no but why are you
saying that because in Islam you can do
that it's not it's not forbidden it's
Halal to do that he said no you're
stupid I'm going to kill this man who's
coming to to your da so this I'm I'm
very confused you know about uh how to
proceed and I try to get contact on
because I have follow
on but this dream though this dream like
we're with you 100% that Islam is false
and I know that that that choke you up a
lot because this is what you grew up
believing is true so I understand that's
important for you that's why you keep
going back to it but Jesus is literally
appearing in your
dreams like that that is not that's not
a joke he wants you to come to him he
wants you to repent and come to him he's
there for you he's waiting for
you you know how much a blessing my
nephew me and my nephew have talked
about to go to a church and talk to
someone and see cuz um oh that's that's
a great idea that's a great idea yeah so
that's first step we doing that and he
said to me that is more sense to follow
religion that
uh you know you can if you read he said
I have read about Jesus when I read
about him I feel like I am this man but
when I read about Muhammad oh my God
it's it's like I'm a killer exactly
exactly you see it man glory to God you
see it praise God yeah so may may he
continue to draw you um he sees your
heart and he hears you man he hears you
um and and he's and he's drawing you
this is there's a good reason why keep
moment sorry yeah but that's God man
that's God you know you're feeling the
presence of God right now that's what
you feel no I'm really shaking man
it's we believe you we believe you yeah
the the Holy Spirit has his way man he
he has his way of of drawing us and and
making himself known this this is this
is it's it's really interesting you have
people who like you who have experiences
where God continues to come to them over
and over because he comes after his
sheep the Bible says that you know out
of the 99 if there's one that's left
behind he goes after the that one he's
going after he's going after you my
brother he's coming after you and all
you have to do is say yes that's all you
have to do yeah trust for me I'm I'm
just uh you know I'm just I'm confused
because my brother is
um he he he's uh he's on a really dark
path and I'm I'm trying to talk to him
and he
doesn't makes no sense you know you you
know how much love you have in your
heart for your brother and how much you
want him to be on the right path Jesus
loves him infinitely more than anyone in
this world could ever love him because
he's his creator yeah and he came to
this Earth was unived on the cross for
his sins and he rose from he rose from
from that as well so he loves your
brother he wants your brother to be
saved but you have to focus right now
the Bible says today is the day of
salvation we don't know what's promised
for tomorrow we don't know what's going
to happen tomorrow right you could you
might not wake up tomorrow I might not
wake up tomorrow we don't know we don't
know the future but you have Jesus
appearing to you in dreams like he's
literally knocking on your heart telling
you come to me come to me
and and then everything else with your
family that can all come afterwards but
right now you need to focus on your
relationship with
God the thing is why I'm being question
is because of when I got my two kids and
I was starting you think
okay what shall I teach them because
they ask now a little bit older now they
are seven eight then asking me dad who's
God you'll be able to teach him the
truth once once you learn it once you
learn it yeah yeah yeah um look look if
you want to we'll pray with you right
now if you want to pray I don't know if
you feel comfortable doing that we'll
pray with you right now if you want to
yeah I feel comfortable go to the church
yeah you said you feel comfortable I I I
I I will try to do that because uh yeah
he said yeah you said you said you feel
comfortable it's it's hard to
um you know
uh because you brainwash since kid you
know that if you leave this religion you
are like a cfer you they
will you know what I
mean I get it bro we get it it's like
um um let us pray for you brother let's
let's let's pray for
you yeah go ahead
John you you you wanna you want to lead
brother uh you want to lead in prayer
yeah you yeah sure no problem so uh
Heavenly Father we thank you uh we thank
you for this brother zoo we thank you
for you drawing him we thank you for um
being attentive to him and Lord I thank
you in advance that you have heard his
cry you've hear his heart how he has a a
heart for the truth and he has a heart
for his brother who is being lost and
led and and misguided on the wrong path
Lord God we ask right now in the name of
your son that you send your spirit into
his household that not only him but his
entire household and anyone that's close
in relation to him is drawn to your
truth and is saved Lord God we pray Lord
God that you send your power your Mighty
power your power of spe your peace your
power of healing your power of
discernment your power of Truth and that
he comes into into the knowledge of you
and is saved and then thus by you saving
him the rest of his family can see the
goodness and what to taste your goodness
Lord I ask that you pull him out of the
darkness fully um give him the
confidence and the boldness and the
courage to step fully in you and to
trust you Lord God give him the gift of
faith Lord give him the gift of faith
this is what we pray in the name of the
father Son and Holy Spirit Hallelujah
the name of Jesus amen amen thank you
for the praise man appreciate it I
appreciate it of course um yeah zo uh
those dreams um you said that he tell
you to read uh what do you remember any
other details he said to me uh the thing
is it happens many things in in my life
because
uh
uh I have lost many things in life
because of businesses I have my own
business and I always pray to Allah
please Allah help me please but never
never I I I don't get what I pray for
you
know but so these dreams the thing is
these dreams I had there's a white when
I say white man like shiny shiny he's he
he was he was
white uh I mean the clothes was white
but I couldn't see his face yeah because
because you know why you could see his
face because that's the glory of God it
was shiny it was bright yeah and then
when he told me that this B you on this
thing you on is not good take this Pat
but I haven't seen the pat yet you
understand so that's why I'm starting to
question things you know okay how can I
proceed from this and my brother is is
is doing this
and my God he from the beauty he had
before from if you look at him now and
before you can see how dark he had
become because of
one religion that is uh corrupted in my
so in true lives I don't know if you
guys have feeling that sometime when
something happening in my life that it's
like someone telling me turn around
don't go this way or uh how should I say
when I encounter danger or something in
life is like someone is pushing me or
someone is touching my
shoulder that don't don't go this path
this is not
good okay
okay let me ask you this have you read
have you read the go do you know the
gospel no I haven't I have not uh read
any of the Bible only read the are you
familiar with the with the gospel the
good news of
Jesus no nothing I haven't studied any
of
it I I'm trying to understand my the
religion i in it and I'm getting
confused every time you know I
I hear because when I read about the
Hadith and I say
okay how can this had be
true when I ask the other people do you
speak
Russian no okay so what what L send
follow me send me a and follow God logic
we'll follow you back and we'll try to
follow up with you on some we'll help
we'll try to help you out further in uh
private but we don't want you to expose
anything sorry
sorry I I I took your time and no no so
don't because I can't prove Muhammad in
the Bible I'm trying to prove for myself
if this is the man I'm gonna follow or
not I don't believe in him so much
because I lost faith when I read about
Aisha that's the part because I have a
daughter myself yeah and I can't imagine
my myself to give my daughter to a man
is that's 50 years old that's sick for
me in my world that's
sickness wow y we agree with you 100%
that's why we reject his Z as
well zo what I would do is I would I
would get yourself um a Bible get
yourself a Bible read it in in your
language your the native language and go
through the gospel go through the
gospels you can start with the Gospel of
John and start from the beginning go all
the way to the end and just read it goel
of John Gospel of John yeah can I just a
second and
um we can we can give you a translation
in your language if you
want yeah I understand English your
English is is it's perfect I'm just
saying if you want to read your own
language that's up to you uh my own
language
no I can't read it sorry cuz I you left
uh my country uh I I run away from Iraq
when I was 4 years old and I run away I
come to Iran I run away
under to Sweden oh wow so I have seen
many things I have seen dead people I
have seen my cousin they cut his head
off when I was four years
old wow because yeah I've been through a
lot it's incredible oh
wow wow okay
well let let's just tell you what what
the gospel is because you said you
didn't know what the gospel is are you
aware of anything about what Christians
believe or are you just like you're just
learning now or no I'm I'm learning and
I'm trying to learn because I'm now uh
the thing is I'm I'm read about the
Hadith and you know I I always have a
question since I was young why we are
only yeah you know you know about the
the the garden that Adam was in
the paradise the garden that Adam was in
yes Paradise the Jenna okay yes do you
know um how many how many sins did Adam
need to commit to get kicked out of
paradise how many sins yeah
sins no I don't know just just one right
just one right so the way the Bible says
it is you know I know the Quran is a
little different on this but he forbade
one tree don't eat from this tree and
what did Eve do ate from the tree Adam
eat from the tree and then they were
kicked out of the garden right yeah yeah
so one sin just one sin one sin can
separate us from
God so now we're left with this problem
of sin how do we yeah how do we get rid
of this sin and bring us back into this
relationship with God that we had at the
beginning this perfect relationship with
God without sin and the answer to that
is through
Jesus Jesus giv us the way and what
Jesus did was this is God who took on
flesh he entered into flesh became a
human a human nature added a human
nature to
himself and he lived a perfect life
without any sin at all something that
you and I couldn't do we couldn't do
that because we've sinned before but he
lived a perfect life without
sin and the punishment
that's why I resemble sorry I'm
interrupting that's why I resemble with
Jesus more than muhamad he was sinless
and and it gives me perfect example this
I told my perample exactly look at him
by way why does man have 11 wives by
Jesus Jesus referred to a 12-year old
girl a 12-year-old as a little girl by
the way the little girl okay not someone
that you married he called her a little
girl Mark chapter 5 ver 41 41 so so
let's just so Jesus lived perfect life
the sinless life and he took the
punishment that was due for me and for
you for all of us on himself yeah so
that punishment that we have built up
for ourselves from all the sin that
we've committed just like that one sin
that Adam committed took him out of the
garden took him out of paradise that one
sin we've committed hundreds of
thousands of millions of sins knowingly
and unknowingly in our life Jesus took
that punishment on himself the
consequences of our sins fell on on him
so he was crucified on the cross he's
the perfect atonement the perfect
atonement for our
sins and he took that punishment the
consequences for us on
himself and he died and rose from the
dead three days later he defeated death
forever and ever and now you can have a
relationship with
God so that when God looks at you he
doesn't see any sin at all he doesn't
hold anything against at all
and you believe and you believe in what
Jesus did for
you and this makes sense more than uh
Muhammad because uh I always ask my
mother how come we cannot ask question
to Imam this this is Haram and this is I
have to know man I have to know how
should I proceed but as soon as I ask
this question no my friend this is
forbidden it's not good to ask this
question yes no so it makes sense don't
have the correct answer let me read to
you in ROM Romans chapter 10 what it
says it says if you confess if you
confess with your mouth that Jesus is
Lord and you believe in your heart that
God raised him from the dead you will be
saved for with the heart One Believes
and is
Justified and with the mouth one
confesses and is saved for the scripture
says everyone who believes in him will
not be put to shame There's no
distinction between Jew and Greek for
the same Lord is Lord of fall bestowing
his riches on all who call on him for
everyone who calls on the name of the
Lord will be
saved so Zozo oh wow do you call on the
name of
Jesus like I told you I have to you have
to study it out you don't have to do it
right now I have to study and and I have
to study and I'm not saying that I'm not
going to come to Christ or not no uh the
door is open for me and I have a a guy
asked me actually to come to church I I
I went Church two times and it felt very
light to come in there yeah you know why
you know why look let me show you why it
feels light because this is what the
Lord Jesus Christ said and Matthew
chapter Matthew chapter
11 Matthew chapter 11 starting in verse
28 Jesus says come to me all you who
labor and are heavy laden and I will
give you rest take my yoke upon you
learn from me for I am gentle and lowly
in heart and you will find rest for your
souls for my yoke is easy and my burden
is
light so that what you feel at the
church that light feeling that peace
that you feel that Comfort that's God
that's the presence of God
Amen well I I felt very very easy when I
came into the church and I said to my
friend wow is this like this all the
time surprised by
it he said you should come more often I
say I will try because I'm I don't know
so keep on going keep going brother keep
going keep going well I hope that uh I
hope that we we're able to help you some
and um yes I'm going to definitely
follow you guys and uh see if I can get
some help on the way and sorry make sure
you take it serious make sure you take
it seriously not not Jesus doesn't
appear to everybody in a dream I mean so
make sure you take it very seriously
yeah that if you're seeing Jesus in
dreams you need to take that very
seriously yeah so consider what we said
um brother Avery he prayed for you we're
going to pray for you everyone here all
the brothers and sisters we'll keep
praying for you but take it very
seriously think about what we said and
pleas goel of John that's why that's the
reason I'm here because I have follow
God God logic and I it makes perfect
sense all the debates I see I see him
this man is brave man how can he manage
to talk with this all this
people they have no education on the
mind the ignorance how this guy can have
his shield I mean I'm so baffled and
Amazed by this guy and he's a true hear
in my eyes because he's a Ser he's a
servant of Jesus Christ that's why he's
a servant of Jesus Christ yeah man it's
it's unbelievable and I have seen him
many
time and that's why that's the reason I
came up and said oh wow he's online
let's try to talk to him maybe I can get
a chance and you know God express myself
see what I can learn from you glory to
God wow glory to God well well like like
J said my brother we're here whenever
you need us so just just hit us up okay
yes I uh so I'm going to follow you guys
and see if I can yeah per please do
follow us we'll follow you back and
we'll try we'll try to follow up with
you in
private yes thank you thank you God
bless you Zoo God bless Zoo thank you
man that that is praise
God he's right there he's he's right
there and God that that is what a a
prime example and we've seen this all
year J we've been seeing this all year
yes God changing people's hearts the
this brother is saying that that g that
he's seeing Christ in his dream three
times three times three times man wow
you know not not even not I I'm I don't
get that type of that type of
L luxury right oh man I'm so I'm so
amazing man yeah God I'm righteously
jealous of that that's it's it's awesome
um so yeah everybody that's watching man
we have 13 people 1300 people watching
on on uh YouTube guys hit the like on
the stream and also pray for Zozo pray
for Zozo man he's right there he said
his heart is open and you heard it um
keep praying for him next time we talk
to him
most likely he will uh he'll be a new
brother wow and then he will be a
witness for his
family that that man that's amazing and
he felt the presence of God as we were
talking to him too he said he was
shaking he said he wow y that's how it
is guys that's how it is keep praying
for him and and and and God will use him
as an instrument to to minister to his
family that's just how that's how he
does it that's how God works
amen amen okay wow